Congress is taking its fight into the
holidays a lawyer for the House
Judiciary Committee says Democrats are
open to impeaching President Trump again
if new evidence of obstruction emerges
the comment was part of a petition to
interview former White House Counsel Don
McGann and in a letter to colleagues
Senate Democratic leader chuck schumer
wrote that leaving new evidence out of a
Senate trial quote would be to turn a
willfully blind eye to the facts that
brought pushback from his Republican
counterpart Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell chip Reid is traveling with
the president who is at his Resort and
Palm Beach Florida chip is the president
responding at all well we might hear
from him about all this later today
he'll be holding a video conference with
members of the military and perhaps
he'll take a few questions from the
press in the meantime the Senate is
battling over how his impeachment trial
should proceed it's gonna seem to most
of the American people that it is a sham
trial Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
doubled down on his demand for key White
House documents that he believes will
shed light on the decision to freeze and
then release millions in aid to Ukraine
it's hard to imagine a trial not having
documents and witnesses Democrats won at
least four officials to testify at the
Senate trial including acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney and former national
security adviser John Bolton Republican
leader Mitch McConnell opened the door
slightly to that possibility Monday we
haven't ruled out witnesses we've said
let's handle this case just like we did
with President Clinton during President
Clinton's impeachment trial there were
opening arguments a written question
period and then senators decided which
witnesses to call McConnell also
responded to Schumer's criticism that he
was not an impartial juror do you think
Chuck Schumer is impartial do you think
a little bit warrant is impartial no
Bernie Sanders is impartial so let's
quit the charade this is a political
exercise a political exercise McConnell
says the Senate can't move ahead until
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi transmits the
articles of impeachment which she has
yet to do Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman Lindsey Graham threatened
Monday to cut Pelosi
of the process entirely tweeting if she
refuses Senate Republicans should take
matters into our own hands we are in
charge of the Senate not Pelosi or
Schumer but Republican leader McConnell
has indicated that that is not an option
that they have no choice but simply wait
for Nancy Pelosi to act dana chip thank
you
you